foreign
one of my faves UFOs have long been a source
of mystery and Fascination in 1951's The Day
the Earth Stood Still Hollywood imagined what
would happen if an alien spaceship landed on
the capitol mall well this week a U.S government
agency charged with investigating unidentified
flying objects released its annual report and
David Martin has the details on what was found
oh God this is just one of 510 UFO sightings
mostly by Navy and Air Force pilots over the
past two decades more than half of which remain
unexplained it does become increasingly clear that
unidentified aerial phenomenon are not a rare
occurrence last year Congressman Andre Carson
chaired the first public hearing on what the
government calls unidentified aerial phenomena
it provided precious few answers about where
they came from I would simply say that there
are a number of of events in which we do not
have an explanation this week a new report from
the Director of National Intelligence revealed
that 169 sightings turned out to be balloons or
some kind of Airborne clutter while 26 turned
out to be drones the obvious question is whose
drones precisely I mean are they drones from our
U.S military are they drones from the private
sector are they drones from other state actors
who are also adversaries these green triangles
cited by Navy ships off the coast of California
in 2019 turned out to be drones they appeared at
the same time Chinese Merchant vessels were in
the area there's no proof the drones came from
those ships but one U.S official said China is
highly suspect in all these sightings now we've
got 510 has any physical evidence such as debris
been recovered the debris that has been recovered
has not raised any notable alarms and that's
as much as I'll say in other words no alien
spacecraft but there are still UFOs that maneuver
in ways that baffle America's best fighter pilots
and the man who was once their commander-in-chief
we can't explain uh how they moved their
trajectory you know I think that we're people
still take seriously trying to investigate and
figure out what that is intelligence agencies have
now been ordered to extend their investigation
all the way back to 1947 when the crash of a
weather balloon in Roswell New Mexico set off
the decades-long search for UFOs for CBS Saturday
morning this is David Martin at the Pentagon
yes those 40 years before the last 20 I'm
interested in it's great fun to talk about yeah
no notable alarms notable no notable alarms okay
just a second very nice thank you David Martin